So I've never
driven a car blind before
but here we go!
God damn!
AHAHA!
You're gonna die!
So today we're going to try something that i've been wanting to do for a while
It's an idea I had called Video Game Simulator
Wren was messing with his Tiny Whoop Drone
and we thought it would be fun to run behind around with a camera
as in a third person video game camera angle.
So, I've decided to take it probably to take a couple of steps too far
and I've built this rig here,
where it has a radio-controlled camera, the battery and all the transmitters
as well as a GoPro right here so we can record it.
Somebody's going to put the goggles on
and they're going to run a Grand Theft Auto obsticle course here
while they can only see themselves from third person camera view.
I have made Sam volunteer
I have no idea what's going on.
Oh, so I can see myself
Go and walk, let's try it out!
So your framing is pretty shit right now
it's canted making me kinda ... there we go, that's better.
Up or down?
Down.
That's better, yeah.
I think you are right there,
Uh, you're a little bit off.
There?
Yeah.
This isn't a challenge for me
So much as it is for me as for Niko.
Stop running faster than this.
Oh god! Dude
This is gonna be a little crazy!
So, what we're gonna do in this GTA Simulator,
Sam is going to have to mug Wren,
Steal his keys to the car
and jack the car,
drive in about 40 feet down in this big empty street,
hop out and then kill the one opposing gang member.
With a Nerf gun, just like GTA!
You didn't say anything about driving a car
Ok, let's just do it.
I'm just ... let's just ... let's go.
Let's just do it yeah!
We'll just see what it's like as if real life was GTA.
I'm ready to do this!
Let's do it. Let's go!
We're loading in!
I came in with a T-pose, then I gotta go limp.
There.
Dude, this guy wants to start some shit?
Hey!
I got his hand!
Oh, right in the face!
You got the keys!
I got 'em!
I got the keys!
Let's do this!
Come on!
Where is it?
It's right here!
So, I've never driven a car blind before,
but I can see the whole car right now.
I can't see the dashboard,
warning signals or anything, but here we go!
God damn!
Ah haha!
You're gonna die!
Whoah!
Oh, this is so weird!
Oh my god! I can't see anything!
There's a car passing to our left, just so you know.
No, we're gonna stop.
No, I'm not gonna...
Where's Wren?
Hey Sam, we got someone coming up here.
Wren?
Yep.
Oh, I see him!
Alright, I think the car's off, right?
Oh, there he is.
*Groans*
I can't see, Niko. Aim that shit, dude!
I can't ... that's right, there.
Yay, I did it! I did it!
You did it!
Let me go and take his money!
That was chaos. That was so chaotic.
I loved it though.
How was it? - Dude Sam,
You shot me right in the forehead! Right here!
Keeping up with the car is really hard.
I'm starting to go faster then we discussed.
It did feel like GTA.
I'm going to try and operate the camera and give Niko the chance,
I'm gonna try make a few improvements on the camera work,
make it so it's even easier for Niko to hit Wren in the balls.
Alright, I'm legit nervous,
Alright, cool. Let's do it!
It's a WrenPC!
Ready to load in?
Yeah!
What's your character's name?
serverdude420
Loading in, go for it!
That is so awkward!
This is the one!
It's really hard!
Go for it, bro!
Got 'em!
Got the keys!
He's moving!
Oh my god! This is so intense!
It's actually...
It's easier than walking though.
Like, I can actually see where I'm going just fine,
I can totally see where my car's pointing
Alright.
Yes!
I did it!
If I'm off center in the third-person camera,
like, I can't just flip the thumbsticks center forward,
and make myself go straight again,
like, I have to physically turn my body
and go in a new direction and see what happens.
I think we should up the stakes: GTA Online stlye!
'Cause I actually built another one of these poles
and we have another set of goggles.
So we can do 1v1, third-person camera GTA fighting,
It's gonna be really janky.
Let's do it!
Wasted.
Alright, we're gonna up the stakes here for the very end.
Sam and I are gonna be cameramen,
and we're gonna be picking our soldiers.
Sam, I will give you the first pick
between Wren and Jimmy.
Jimmy, let's do this!
Yeah! Let's go!
Alright, Wren,
Man! I have Niko?
We're gonna equip both Jimmy and Wren with Nerf guns.
Whoever shoots the other person the most
by the time they've emptied their mags,
wins the fight.
The winner, get's the hambone jar.
No! No! That is...
That, no...
That means you could earn all your money back!
Or you lose it!
You see it? -Yeah, this is good.
That's a sweet in the pot.
That was a hard landing!
So, Wren fights the best when he is bleeding.
So, we've made sure we scraped himself up,
before we got started.
We're gonna crush this and Wren is gonna get all the hambones.
When you're aiming your gun,
make sure it is a big obvious motion
that I can aim down the gun like a little bit for you.
Ok, alright.
I'm gonna fly this right in,
You're gonna be looking down your iron sights
as you aim. Ok?
Ok.
I'll just walk around like this,
Or you could just go like horse stance
I'll be directly behind you like this,
So this time, we're gonna show you the GoPro footage,
because it's a lot cleaner and nicer to look at.
Alright, they're ready.
Go!
Give me that camera angle!
Which one is Wren?
Oh god!
Wait!
I'll kill him!
Solid shot!
Niko, your aiming sucks!
Ow!
You're out Jimmy!
I'm out!
Game over guys! Game over!
It was good. It was good. Once I got my bearings,
turns out I'm just the best.
How many times have I hit him?
Like a lot. 'Cause you also got a direct like, a frickin' direct forehead shot on.
All I saw was Jimmy got a head shot on Wren and that's it,
that's a win in my book, right there. -Yeah.
Wren, you know it was a nice try.
You hit me once, Wren, in the hand.
Just once!?
Yeah, just once.
Wren, do you want those hambones?
Yeah.
We can probably talk him into one more round,
If we swapped, and I fought for you.
Oh well. I'll probably do a much better camera job then you did.
I'm not gonna argue with that,
I don't think you guys know this but, I'm a great camera man.
Which one is Sam?
Give me some space! Give me some space!
Wide angle!
Get down. Get down.
You getting some cover?
Let's go around,
I don't see...
Whoo!
My gun broke.
Wren, point the camera!
Never!
I can't retreat!
Retreat!
Alright. Alright.
Yes!
Fate decreet me over.
Alright. That was great,
we had technical difficulties but at the end of the day,
I don't think it was about the competition.
Good old fun, shoot your friends with a weird camera setup setting.
So, I can go home and say I was a winner, right?
Yes -Yeah you beat me.
Let us know what you thought of this little video game simulator experiment.
We got some other cool ideas we'll try down the line.
Side-scroller simulator.
Like Mario series, somebody running sideways through the camera,
while you have to have the goggles on and jump over shit.
Can't, it would just make everyone throw-up
Yeah,
Like, there could be a Kooper shell and a skateboard coming at you
and you have to jump over it,
but you won't actually be able to judge where it is.
That's one where we would actually wear the helmets.
Yeah, we do have Mario and Luigi helmets.
Thanks so much.
Well, you're gonna make another hambone jar after that one for sure.
Yeah, definitely.